nos encontramos en la población de John
pill en la provincia de dones muy cerca
a la provincia de Luján prácticamente
ocupada por las fuerzas rusas y es una
población que ha estado en el medio de
la batalla desde el comienzo de la
invasión a gran escala los rusos tomaron
su control en su momento luego fue
liberada por las fuerzas ucranianas A
mediados de octubre en el mes de octubre
pero desde entonces las batallas no han
parado los enfrentamientos entre unos y
otros son constantes segundos contaba la
población la hemos visitado en varias
oportunidades pero en invierno había
muchísima más gente a pesar de que no
tenían electricidad y no tenían agua en
el día de hoy lo que nos hemos
encontrado es casi nadie civiles en la
calle nos dicen que solamente queda el
10% y las enfrentamientos se han ido
intensificando como lo confirmaba en los
últimos días la viceministra de defensa
que dice que las tropas rusas están
tratando de avanzar en este frente
conocido como el de criminal Es bathoven
según nos cuentan algunos integrantes
del ejército con los que estuvimos esta
mañana Ellos están tratando de presionar
en los últimos días con artillería con
tanques con Infantería de una manera que
no habían visto en las últimas semanas
con el grupo que estuvimos nos contaban
que al frente de ellos hay ejército
profesional ruso sin embargo en otros
flancos están utilizando estos convictos
que sacan de las cárceles rusas y
utilizan en grupos y que mandan como
Carne de cañón para tratar de romper las
defensas ucranianas y así presionar más
a estas tropas esto es al día de hoy uno
de los lugares más delicados para el
ejército ucraniano como hemos podido
comprobar esta mañana donde no paran los
cruces de artillería como ya lo habían
confirmado en los últimos días las
autoridades ucranianas